at number 14 Juha Pekka from Finland is
having a well-earned play bridge can he
build it yes he can this boundary
breaking builder is using a 20 tonne
excavator to assemble tiny toy blocks I
have no idea how we did it you can
hardly see these bricks from the cab let
alone get them in the right place yeah
how is this even possible is it an
excavator designed for moving massive
objects in all things it's quite a
ridiculous idea because it's using
completely the wrong tool for the job
excavators use hydraulics to transmit
power from a pump to the head of the
claw hydraulics use a incompressible
fluid such as oil this means that if you
apply pressure at one end that can't be
squeezed and the pressure is transferred
to somewhere else in the system if you
look at the excavator you can see in
tubes in some places and much wider
Pistons in others by pushing in where
it's thin you don't have to use as much
force that pressure though is the same
at the other end it is a bigger area and
that gives you a much bigger force that
means that this excavator is really
great and making big powerful movements
but it's really hard to make these
really small movements and pick up these
bricks so how is uhaah operating this
monster machine with such skill and
dexterity when you play with toy blocks
you're getting constant feedback from
your touch the driver of the excavator
though doesn't get that he's just
pushing a button to move the bits around
he has to try and look to see what's
happening and adjust accordingly the one
clever trick that makes the whole thing
possible is he's building on a padded
surface this way if he accidentally
moves it too far instead of crushing the
block he just pushes it into the padded
surface
which means there's no denying the scale
of you--has achievement